so I'm Lila it's a tremendous honor to
be here tonight it means a great deal to
me because when I started out I I came
to fry was born in France that I was
just telling some of you by accident I
am of Iranian descent and we left the
country because a revolution occurred
and revolution in which we lost
everything and it's not something that I
often talk about because I don't think
Iran has much to do with my love of
literature although it's connected to it
of course but the reason why I'm telling
you now is because I think it's
pertinent to why we are here today and
when we when we left Iran and we came to
France we had lost almost everything we
had lost people in our family we had
lost things that belonged to our family
and we had lost our country the one
thing that my mother wanted me to
inherit as an Iranian child in exile was
the love of culture the love of books
and that began with curiosity
it began with always going somewhere it
started with walking with going with
asking a question and we're trying to
see sparkles and things you know I look
at that piece of little beauty look at
that piece of bridge it's so beautiful
there's a bit of sunshine on the bridge
look look look at that painting you know
look look at look at look at the sea
over there and it all starts with this
moment of being being just surprised and
in French it's called Eton MO and it
learn more in Greek is tamas Ain to be
surprised and that's where that's where
philosophy begins it's with that moment
of wonderment and my mother thought that
if I learned if I had an education if I
was able to learn in books in paintings
with music and keep it within myself
then I would have a portable home with
me forever
and I would never be I would have a home
everywhere I would never be an exile I
will never be in need for things or
hungry to put things on myself or to
look for outside satisfactions and
that's why I'm here tonight because I
want to share with you a little bit of
that love a little bit of that curiosity
a little bit of that wonderment and
enchantment that makes living worthwhile
so just to begin I wanted to show you
two excerpts since we are going to talk
about love and especially tonight about
first love
I'll show you two examples of first love
because I think we can talk about we'll
talk about to gain EF and quite
specifically I'd love to talk we'll have
three students Joe flip and Sacha who
will talk about the book with us and
then please you are all welcome to
participate but we'll also think about
first love in general and stories why do
we tell stories when we're in love who
do we tell the stories to and when are
those stories literature and why why
literature makes us better lovers so
let's begin with an excerpt from a film
called the lover which was made in 1992
by jean-jacques I knows one of the best
French filmmakers of his generation it's
inspired by a book by the wonderful
margaritas and it was an
autobiographical biographical story when
she was a young girl living I believe in
Saigon and I read the book very many
times and also very long time ago and
she falls in love she breaks all the
codes and her first love is a Chinese
man and much older than she is and from
from a different social background from
a different ethnic background than her
own so she breaks all the code and
here's first love so if we can please
see the first exit
time 17 and Playboy
all hail jean-jacques Uno's brilliant
new film when we cut the light one of
the most provocative cinematic
experiences of our time the lover
you
we are lovers everyday we go back to the
bachelors room we can't stop loving
he does nothing only love is that what
you are yes
I'm going to die love for you
you
how many people have read margaritas in
this room has anybody read manga yes my
good to us
I encourage whoever hasn't read the book
to read it immediately tomorrow
it's an extraordinary book and the movie
is good actually I don't think the movie
is bad it looks very romantic and very
lush but the book is so much better and
I wanted to see as a second excerpt
another kind of first love a movie that
just won the Palme d'Or at can called
blue is a warmest colour has anyone seen
it already yes yes yes so we're going to
see an excerpt of that
so what I like about this trailer is the
assertion that this perhaps the first
great love story of the 21st century
I remember when Lolita was published by
a vintage there was there was a Vanity
Fair article that came out and said the
first great love story of the 20th
century and if one is to go back in time
what I'm also interested in in these
trailers is that there are commonalities
there is something that in literature in
this in the field of literature we call
a trope a trope is something that occurs
over and over again that is a common
it's like a common occurrence now what
happens here
for instance flow Barre flow Barre calls
it alleles used to Hong Kong hair and
their eyes met you see the girl in this
film guys meet trope trope it's typical
you will have it from tree Stowe in his
old from medieval literature in the
twelfth century to the first was
supposedly the first great love story of
the 21st century the eyes meet there is
always there is always a sequence there
the eyes meet and then there is a first
talk and then there's fear and there's
you overcome that fear so um on the one
hand really the the notion the ideal of
love and the way that love is talked
about hasn't changed very much at all
since the beginning of time if you if
you look at the Odyssey for instance you
know whenever when when Odysseus is
taken is taken with the nymph Calypso
and the way he looks at her and Caesar
and is attracted or with Circe the
sorceress it's very much the same thing
it's that magic that infatuation that
there is something almost an
impermissible space that you can't cross
and that suddenly you do cross so what
what is love will be our first question
what is love love can be many things of
course it can be infatuation it can be
desire it can be filled with the Greek
called philia which is friendship it can
be eros which is errata sysm
but mostly I think in literature and
when we speak about first love what we
really mean is passion is that
passionate love now what is passion and
does anybody know there the root of the
meaning passion of the word passion what
does it mean to suffer exactly it's
exactly the same root as patients its
patio and Latin to suffer so in a way
love is also is suffering and at one
point there is I think it's it's it has
it's in this book or it's in another
check off book because I'm just reading
a month in the country as well a
character says well you know I wanted to
he wanted to fall in love which means
that he just wanted to suffer and be
tremendously unhappy so there is that
there is that element and of course in
all of literature it's in first love
first passion there's an element at
times of unrequited love
since paths in suffering is so much part
of passion and what interests me most is
that there's often not always but
there's often like you see here there is
often an element of transgression and
that's another extremely important trope
there is a wonderful wonderful French
intellectual called do need Ahuja mo and
he wrote a book called l'amour he looks
he don't love in the Western world I
really encourage you to read the needles
more it is one of the best books I have
ever read it is tremendously
illuminating on our culture who we are
why we write the books that we write and
why we read the books that we read and
he says the West has been obsessed with
adultery not as passion but adulterous
passion and he delves deeply into why is
it why what is at the end of the day
what is this passion of adultery now
it's not the topic of tonight so I will
I won't go into it but and why are we so
obsessed with passion and and and you
should absolutely read the hormone to to
find out what he says about that it's
almost the there's a there's a death
instinct and the passion instinct and he
analyzes why
but what hormone also may
only explains is that love-in in our
cultures is always and I coming from an
Eastern a culture of the Eastern or of
the continent of Asia I can say it
definitely expands also to to the
cultures of the East that there's always
an element of transgression that's why I
was interested in showing you these two
quick examples that I think each in
their own ways or the one is the
representation of a novel and the other
one is a film but it's a very literary
film they both represent transgression
now usually love can often or this
notion of passionate love often comes
with an obstacle and the transgression
of an obstacle and that is what
interests us mainly in the literature of
love that there is something to be
conquered and usually there is a price
there is a price to be paid there is a
price and unhappiness a price in terms
of the lives and the suffering of others
but somehow this transgression is also
deeply pleasurable and I don't know how
many of you have read Lolita by Nabokov
yes and at one point one of my favorite
passages of Lolita is when Humbert
Humbert is driving his car at the very
end of the novel and he says that he's
driving on the wrong side of the highway
and and and he's driving there and he
winds up crashing in another car and
basically that summarizes the act of
transgression he is going he's driving
counter to the normal traffic and in a
way I think that when we fall in love
and it all starts with first love I
think for me all love is always all
passionate love somehow is always
transgressive and and I think we we all
dream somehow of always being the ones
driving on the wrong side of the highway
I think that's that's a fantastic
fantasy both for lovers and for artists
and there's a connection between love
lovers of course and the act of being an
artist and that's what I want us to
think about altogether tonight
but if we think also of the connection
between love and stories if we think
about what is the connection what is
this chemical I remember I read might
the book I'm writing right now is about
love and it's set in 14th centuries
that's why I've been reading a
tremendous amount about the questions as
well and I read a very stupid and
annoying book usually I adore science
and I wish I could be a scientist and I
wish I lived a thousand years and could
know everything there is to know about
everything and I've been especially
interested in New York neuroscience so I
was very excited to read a book by a
neuroscientist about love and so she she
plugged electrodes on the brains of many
X numbers of patient and she saw what
what lit up and apparently the amygdala
and I don't want to speak nonsense so
apologies to the scientists out there if
I'm just speaking utter nonsense but I
believed something in the middle
very went off all the time and then
hormones and all kinds of things and and
by accident I I had lunch with a
wonderful psychiatrist who's a head of
Cornell psychiatry who happens to be a
great lover of Nabokov in New York and I
said I just read this horrific book that
that minimizes everything to the brain
lighting up and chemicals firing
everywhere and this woman says this is
love and if you want to keep up with
love you know make sure those chemicals
are fired all the time and and he said
oh yeah I know you know it's reducing
reducing the human experience to just
pure the purely material but because
there is another element it's not just a
chemicals firing in our brains and the
hormones it's also that is human
creatures we those chemicals or whatever
it is that begins the affair in our
brain and outside of us is also
prompting us to tell stories and that's
really one of the things that defines
our species is to tell stories and not
just to tell stories but to have
patterns in the story what you would
call pattern and play what a great
literary critic called pattern and play
and we tell stories to ourselves now I
think especially in first love maybe but
I feel every love is first love in a
certain way and I think in first love
we're prone to telling ourselves that
our the other person
comes a character in your story are you
oh that person is is looks like he's
fallen out of the 18th century you know
he he could have he could be traversing
Europe on horses he is he has never been
to school you sort of you start telling
yourself stories and you have a horrible
boyfriend basically but you but you you
imagine that that he's the most romantic
character in the planet so you'd start
you you tell yourself stories about the
other but that's interesting you're
already you're already doing the work of
a writer and of an artist when you're in
love you're already telling yourself a
story about the other and in fact and
that's an idea from Marcel post the
French writer in fact Marcel Post
believes that we always tell ourselves
stories about the people we love so much
so then he says that it's our
imagination that's responsible for it
love not the other person so much so
that when the other person your loved
one is there she's actually quite boring
he or she is actually quite boring in
reality and it's very hard to admit that
you're bored to death
you're much better off imagining them
and imagining that they're so romantic
and don't they have long hair and don't
they speak three lovely languages that
you don't understand and all kinds of
things but the reality is so different
and we also tell stories to others
because we want to convince others that
our loves are interesting was in
worthwhile and that's another theory I
went to French school so maybe I I know
the critical literature in French a bit
better I'm sure they're excellent
thinkers in Dutch and and and in English
as well i i know some of the american
and english ones there is another one i
would really recommend you he teaches at
Stanford and and he wrote a book and his
name is Ganesha Ganesha and he wrote a
book called Mosul home on Tiki verite
Romanesque or Mosul yes yes well I never
know which side it is but I think yet it
is most sort of a multi give any
gentleman ask so it which means romantic
lie and novelistic truth and in that
book in a series of other ones
honey jihad develops a theory that I
think is one of the most interesting
series on
love and stories he says we never desire
or love alone one person there's always
a third person involved and the third
person can be a person or an institution
or a thing but usually indicates
indicates to us that that thing is
desirable
so excites our imagination and tells us
hey you know or for instance it begins
it could be in a party at the book in a
book for instance where somebody tells
somebody else that guy he's really sexy
you know and all of a sudden you begin
to think well he looks much better than
he did five minutes ago
and-and-and-and honey AHA believes that
all of desire functions that way we
always desire people or even things we
want to go what is about is this whole
thing of social media and personally I
feel I live in the Middle Ages because I
don't have a camera and I've given up my
blackberry because I think it was
hijacking my brain but when I look at
people taking so many photographs I'm
thinking guys you're gonna put it in
your hard drive you are never going to
see those photographs meanwhile you are
spending your vacation with something in
front of your eyes so we're really
making those photographs not for
ourselves we're making them to show them
to others and to make the places that
we've been to desirable places diet that
might otherwise poor us let's be honest
sometimes vacations can be boring we
want it why do parents the number one
thing that's most photographed on
Facebook is food now that's a mystery
why do we photograph our chocolate ice
cream hell oh I think it's the same
thing I think it tastes better if you
think that somebody on the other end of
the world is looking at it and envying
you for eating your chocolate ice cream
I think exactly the same thing happens
with a lover if you know that your your
sort of your your your kissing a boy
that half of your school thinks is the
hottest boy in the in the class and
you're a little more secure and you like
him a little better and post the great
writer of love and jealousy and and the
obsession they're really the obsession
with love the passionate obsession he
says it's all about the imagination he
says that the first times the first time
he sees
his first love he says on the beach he's
walking on the beach and he says that in
fact that first image of her the real
image was so was perhaps just a tiny
figment of all the succession the
succession of girls that he saw like so
many ballerinas following in succession
but there were all the product of his
imagination
the only real one little Swiss / reality
was that one girl seen so long ago on
the beach walking on the beach all the
other ones were his imagination and does
that make her make the experience of the
one who's in love any less intense no
that's who we are as humans we have to
imagine we have to imagine in order to
be in love and we and the more we
imagine the more exciting love is
sometimes we have to tell stories in
order to make sense sometimes we have to
tell stories in order to fold more
deeply in love now I am guilty of that
sin if I tell a good story about the
person that I'm in love with I feel more
in love with them because my story is
making sense and sometimes we have to
tell the story in order to record our
experiences or to transfigure our
experiences writers are I think very
good liars
but every good lie has a backbone of
truth and you're never as good when you
write as when you write the truth
transfigured into fiction I'm not
interested in reading autobiography or
the sexual life of Kathleen M the book
that came out in France and that was all
about the orgies of this woman who
describes in every single detail her
sexual life that's not literature for me
literature is Transfiguration by an act
of the imagination so sometimes
sometimes these forms combined these
different stories combine and in the
best most beautiful most felicitous of
cases they make literature but I want to
take it one step further
and say that there is also a connection
between love the feeling the
transgression maybe or the infatuation
at least and narrative itself and
stories they're very similar
I think love the way we talk about love
the way we think about love when we say
love is not dissociable from the story
of love that we tell I think the fabric
of love whatever it is I imagine it like
a like a sequences of filaments like DNA
coiling I think that's a story and I
think that the very first fiction in the
world might be Adam and Eve it's a love
story gone a little little wrong but as
all love stories go little wrong there
has to be a twist in the plot and I
think love is not just a story and a
narrative love is the first fiction when
we are in love we are always telling a
story we are already the artists of our
own fictions and that's really powerful
it's empowering to us and and we it's
such a powerful tool and that something
we'll talk about at the end of the
masterclass it's so powerful when you
realize that you are every one of us or
artists of our own love stories it gives
you tremendous powers and with the
tremendous power comes also the
responsibility that you're not in a
novel but you're now a real human being
and a real love story that you can't
just sew lips eyes the other and so
we'll think a little bit about the
ethical implication of this but it's
very powerful I think the real
aphrodisiac is imagination whether it's
in love or it's in errata sysm in fact
post with the autism says the same thing
post says that our pleasures bereft of
imagination would be so sad would be so
sad and and not just post but right at
the Mexican writer Octavio Paz who
warned them who won the Nobel Prize I
think in 90 or 91 talks about it in this
extraordinary book I also encourage you
to read and it's called
flame and he says that the difference
between just plain words or rhetoric and
grammar and poetry is like the
difference between sex that animals can
have - or insects and errata sysm and
errata sysm is imagination so will will
with the three students here we're going
to talk about first love specifically
because I really believe in delving in
specifics in looking at text and looking
well how did how did somebody who had a
truly great mind truly great here truly
great eyes how did they see it and from
there we'll go back to we're opening up
again two more more general ideas about
love and also about why I think that
falling in love is always a rien chant
menteur the world exactly the way that
literature is and that's why reading
reading make turns us into perpetual
lovers of life and everything today in
our culture the worst like the best are
trying to make us live more intensely we
would love to live as if we were on
heroin 24/7 or in a manic trip right but
but the things we do usually are so
completely wrong we think that we think
that if we have two million dollars that
will make us happy we think that if we
travel in very you know privileged
places it will make us happy but the
truth is the cognitive psychologists
tell us that we adapt awfully quickly
and that within a month if you live in a
palace where you have a private jet
you'll be completely used to it and
you'll go back to your biological level
of happiness the only thing that will
really give that high to you and I love
highs I'm always high most of the time
the only way that we'll give that to you
is the imagination and how do you get
unfortunately I like I like fairy tales
too and and some writers some great
writers that I admire very much believe
that all great novels or great fairy
tales because their work of great
fantasy but life itself you know
doesn't look like a fairy tale because
you can't find imagination in a top hat
like a rabbit would come out and you
know you get the rabbit and you and you
ingest it and that's it you have
imagination the fairy tale the the fairy
tale begins when you cultivate the
imagination and that comes only through
the act of reading I like the movie blue
is the warmest color but I have to say I
saw three months ago
the impression made of on me has worn
away I read a book three years ago 20
years ago it's part of my flesh and
blood
it makes me high it still lives with me
it transforms my being in the world it
transforms my experience of the world it
makes me a lover of life so we'll talk
about this book and we'll come back to
to this to this idea